wait
stop thirty one thousand dollars in
profit in one day
using fully automated ai yep
just another day in paradise boys
welcome to the 10 million dollar studio
i'm your host coffee zilla today of
course we're talking about some more
scumbags
listen hey hey hey hey first of all
first of all first things first okay
gotta match this man's energy that's
right off the bat
uh let me say this it's the new hot
thing
right so you thought it was improbable
that a uh 20 something year old could
make successful trades
so you thought that was hard to believe
that he's gonna make you rich
by day trading his way to your success
do you believe that he'd write an ai
script if i use enough buzzwords like ai
bot machine learning automation are you
starting to believe me can i get an amen
from the crowd here
if i say ai do you say i'll give you my
wallet because that's what these people
believe now this is what happens when
you give a man
far too much colombian cocaine and the
crazy thing it is
is by you just watching this video right
now you could have fully
automated your business you can start
making money as
early as a day wait is it a business or
is it trading
hold on one second stop what is it
literally just by clicking the tutorial
okay now look at this guy right here he
made 300 in one day this guy right here
made 600
a day did he bla did he blank out what
the trade was he
said what it did but then he blurred out
the shirt
oh boy we're gonna get into it today
guys
wow sorry i'm having to really look at
that uh trade there
is that not enough this is a psychopath
take it down
and that it's creeping a bit
if you go into business with this guy
you're going into bed with a psychopath
by the way
i know i know some of you guys are like
obviously the joke right no no it's
unlisted and has a bunch of views
meaning they're running ads on it and
then it's something called
fx mode which is uh we're gonna get into
the whole thing
but it's a real service is what i'm
trying to tell you this is their
legitimate pitch
oh yes 1600
oh god damn stuff oh
what oh you're oh goddamn stuff
what's going on you just had a little
second line huh
oh did they do all of that without
having to do any work on their own
because it's fully automated for you
this is what peak human performance
looks like you guys you see a scammer i
see a man
trying to make a living here try to feed
his family do you work a nine-to-five
job
so shut up get off your ass and do what
this guy did
he made ten thousand dollars in one day
without laying a finger on it i feel
like i have to counteract some of his
energy it's it's a lot it's a lot but
this is what it's come to listen
you keep upping the ante look now you
got 19 year olds saying they're
millionaires it's hard to compete with
that
you gotta go full cocaine you gotta pull
a steve ballmer i mean what do you want
me to say
this is literally an extra five to 10k a
month without having to do any work at
all finally
thanks for saying that five to 10k a
month without
having to do anything at all yeah but
it's probably not a get rich quick
scheme though right probably not a get
rich quick scheme
so get off your ass and click the
tutorial and now listen i know this
sounds pretty crazy to you guys but the
thing is we've been doing this for over
a decade now
and have been showing millions i'm not
sure this guy's been alive for a decade
he's like he's a child when did he start
training when he was
seven who is this guy we've been doing
it for 10 years now
who are you i have never seen you before
i don't know who you
are what are your qualifications sir
besides having a perforated nose i mean
jesus all right so you go to the page fx
mode first of all they sell you on a
monthly plan or an
annual plan 2.95 per month to automate
your trades or obviously
19.95 per month now uh why aren't they
just charging management fees
like most people do well you know it's
because
maybe they're not as profitable as they
say they are and if you're not actually
making money it makes more sense to do a
subscription service so
this says how members are making 34k
passively using ai automation
the first day and then uh if you notice
if you
zoom in real carefully there bit of an
asterisk right there well at the bottom
let's see here earnings and income
representations made by david vloss
fx books and their advertisements are
aspirational
and not actually true so okay oh
interesting so when you're saying i'm
gonna make
34k that's what you're hoping for you're
hoping for that
you you guys are hoping for us do you
guys see how scummy that is they bait
you in they go you make 34k
in the first day using ai automation
using the coding bots
got the best traders in the world well
actually what is it it's nothing but
aspirational statements now i actually
went to one of these youtube channels
called
empireambitionsomething.com or something
he actually tested this fx mode and uh
what were his results were they
aspirational did he make 34k in one day
let's find out it's unfortunate but for
fx mode we're gonna have to give this
one two thumbs down
obviously we did not pass testing minus
10.76 percent
oops minus 10 percent hey
they're not gonna quit your job on that
kind of salary also
on trustpilot they have one review it's
a
one star saying nothing but scammers
keep far away from these scammers they
make
outrageous earnings statements on their
website claiming they have a
top ukrainian trader making their trades
for them
when in actual fact all they're using is
a useless ea
robot this site is run by a bunch of
kids who have absolutely no idea what
they're doing
and more importantly he had to get
paypal to force
the refund that they say is uh no
questions asked they promise a
no questions asked refund until you try
to go get it from them now i find it
funny that you have one review on
trustpilot
it's a one star trustpilot goes is this
an average business
is this average for us on trustpilot we
get one guy
one star one review nothing but scammers
trustpilot goes
is this an average business for us
so i picked i have my beef to pick with
uh trustpilot and let's start with your
rating system but how do you have
actually 3.2 that's above average
how can you be above average if you have
a one star
one review one star 3.2 this is insane
anyway so you go to their presentation
right and you go to it you're watching
through
you find out some very interesting
things now in this presentation
uh with beautiful graphics they say that
they have the top trader
in the entire world i don't know what
other way to explain it but
you're fully linked with the top trader
in the world
that's it guys that's that's all you
have to do link up with this
it's a get rich quick scheme if i've
ever seen one and we are the top traders
in the world doing it oh there it is
again
he's the top trader in the world now who
is
this magical top trader who's one of
these top traders well you may remember
from the uh disclaimer
that david vlas is one of these guys now
who's david vloss
oh he's a youtuber oh he's a trading
youtuber right
uh no he's like one of these mr beast
type characters
of like i gave my first subscriber his
dream car
uh surprising my brother with the new
ps5 then destroy maybe he's more like a
prankster i don't
really know oh look at that i copied
stock trading pros
like for a week complete beginner
this is the guy that you're relying on i
mean literally
in the disclaimer this is the guy this
is what i'm talking about guys
the people you're following have no idea
what they're doing
this guy learned what training was
december 24 2020.
oh my gosh i can't take these guys
i know these traders have been trading
since around 2011
and they've been getting crazy results
okay so i guess these are the guys he
teamed up with this decade-long uh
team here they know what they're doing
and they've been trading stocks or they
trade stock options
and sometimes stocks as well they hold
shares long term
but the main thing they do is trade
options every single day that the
market's open
so everybody's an expert now everyone's
just an expert you've been trading for
five days i've been trading for four
days
you can sell me a two thousand dollar
course like no you can't
you can't and you can't promise me these
wild results 34k
in a day and this guy just started
copying trains
what are we doing what
i swear if this is a prank on me maybe
this guy
looks like a prankster right he looks
like a prankster maybe the youtube
channel hasn't been doing well maybe
he's pranking me
i don't know what's going on in all
honesty all i see
is this these crazy promises being made
to kids who are desperate who don't know
who just have heard like ai they think
it's the hype and they hear this
dollars and results so do yourself a
favor and go make money
yeah anyways guys that's basically it
thanks for watching don't fall for the
scams
i appreciate you pumped the only stock
that matters
zilla and i will see you tomorrow